I would delete much of this to your face
I take open Ola wallahi up Shambhala I
am going to delete my channel I'm gonna
say this is my last week this is my last
video on this channel you will delete
your channel delete my channel yes what
if
[Music]
lady so high-level feed the mob
what then
check our sponsors nature's blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the sooner you can also use this
Concord Salam 10 for 10 percent of their
pollen let me ask you a question yeah
I'm sure you have some kind of wisdom
you know whatever it may be you send a
message to a village obviously is to
send that message to a village you need
a messenger yeah you send this messenger
delivers the message to that town or
that village and within about fifty to
hundred years that very people you
delivered or corrupted now with the
human wisdom that you have over the next
cause of action you would have what
would you do over the North next course
of action you you're aware now that the
message you delivered has now been
changed and corrupted okay if I want to
deliver the same message to a larger
audience yeah okay I wouldn't use that
corrupted message I would I would send
them I would send a message again with a
new messenger right yeah okay that was
quite simple now let's put God into the
book you just talked about you know and
I think anyone would do suffuse to ask a
child here God exists God sends a
messenger with a message and that
message gets distorted and corrupted the
question that I want to ask and I'm sure
a lot of people cover what we're talking
about here yeah we're talking to our
Christian but let's be very specific of
which kind of Christians because all
sponsors inherently so so I yeah the
people of the people of the book are not
the same never been their pet yes okay
so now let's talk about those who are
extreme critics of Islam and who are
volkoff's and who are abusive what
you're gonna discuss in another video on
your channel guys you can check that out
God sends a message and this is a very
clear-cut challenge that I'm asking the
Christians Australia the missionaries
the mission of Islam hating missions I'm
out genuinely I know it's hard for them
to be genuine because the fact that
they're attacking the Prophet and
changing his words every single day
shows that just if they could just be
honest and sincere just for two minutes
it would really really help us all so
this is my challenge and should I make
it what you see I would delete much of
this to your face I take open Allah
well I heat up some Billa I am going to
delete my channel I'm gonna say this is
my last week this is my last video on
this channel you will delete your
channel delete my channel yes what if if
they can answer this question genuinely
yeah I will delete my channel what I
mean answer it what we're going to do
some terms the condition of course we're
gonna come to you the question here is
the following God sends a messenger yeah
and he delivers a message that message
gets corrupted what would God do next
okay let me would you understand that
yeah God sends a messenger yes with a
message to a specific village yes for a
specific time yes after the message has
been delivered by the messenger yes the
messenger dies yes or doesn't die yeah
okay disappears disappears right the
message was delivered yeah and the
message gets corrupted because that
message was not meant to be yes forever
yes for everyone yes that's clear right
yeah
God Almighty yes wants to send the same
message yes who a wider audience
yes not to that village once they said
only once so for once and for all no my
option with it would he rely on the same
message that got corrupted which was
sent specifically to that village that's
a good question
in my opinion my rationality tells me
that God would send a message right to
everyone with a new messenger right and
he would ensure that it is not corrupted
okay
if we are wrong yeah if we're disproved
yeah that's the challenge I would delete
my channel here so what we're seeing is
based on our human wisdom that we have
here if I was to do that my next course
of action if our Christian Christian
friends these specific missionaries if
they can answer the very question that
we asked him what would God do we want
you to answer you tell us no no no no
the scripture the Bible is not corrupted
then you're right I'm going to delete my
channel because you have to prove that
it's not corrupted also not only that
Allah says because it's a kind of a
prophecy that says that the Scriptures
have been changed so if it hasn't if you
prove to us
that's the Scriptures hasn't been
changed this challenge video is no point
because the Scriptures have been
corrupted so we're seeing if the
Scriptures are corrupted and people like
Bob and put into a site ok he's faithful
is gonna call it Bruce Smith Scott even
people like Jay Smith you have to it's
like a die-hard pretend I had Christian
I heart Islam hating Christian
missionaries exactly have admit today if
it does the Bible is cooked exactly now
that obviously they say to us look at
least we're honest but we say look we
admire your honesty but if I come and
say I'm a thief when I'm telling you I'm
a thief you should have to watch out for
your pockets next to me you're not gonna
say ok I it's still your honesty weird
my honesty but I still doesn't negate
the fact that the Bible is corrupted yes
so that is our challenge and so the
challenge is to repeat yes just me if
Islam hating missionaries yes Islam
hating missionaries yeah can show Ali
Dawa yes that the Bible has not been
corrupted yes the Old Testament as well
as the New Testament and what the Bible
contains today in the Greek manuscripts
or in the Hebrew manuscripts or in the
translations is exactly what the authors
wrote these are original writings of the
author's ala Dawa will delete the
channel exactly and if you cannot prove
that and you say no we are honest that
our scriptures are corrupted please
answer the following question the
question is the following if you accept
your scriptures are corrupted we're just
asking very simple question anybody that
has an active way of wisdom would answer
what does the course of action would
would God do next well let's see what
would you do next if scriptures were
corrupted the messages sent was
corrupted please please we want a video
video a visual video you answering this
very question what does one do next what
would God do if the scripture is dead
god corrupt it please answer that that's
all we want from you and if you can
prove that to us I'll be the last time
I'll see you guys start conjugant
yes the last sentence yes and the
scripture we are claiming is not corrupt
yes is exactly the same as it was
delivered by the messenger
exactly it is every single word taught
by the Prophet of Islam Prophet Muhammad
to the future generations and that word
has reached us exactly in exactly the
same force yes guys this might be the
last time I see you or maybe it won't be